jairam 70th birthday I've got my two
sons visiting mark who's with link whom
you know and Eric who's Manning the
camera hello hello right so we thought
we'd change the venue of it and we're
ready to go okay so we are here your
solicit questions we unfortunately don't
have time to get to all of them but then
I do its many as we can and then please
keep sending them in and we'll try to
fit all questions in if not this time
then next time for the first question
Steve would you or have you considered
doing live meetups live meetups I mean
yeah sure we can do them if you have
done them we have done the minute we use
Google+ on occasion or sky go live meet
up slicing face-to-face meet ups I think
like oh yeah do them in your for sure
when you go track there and I mean I
don't know if their blinkers in the in
the desert here but I mean I think
you're always quite happy to do
absolutely ups that anybody else let us
know I do if you know where I'm going to
be traveling we'd be happy to meet up
look down over the past mm-hmm and we're
happy to announce it on our forum and
sure and gift spread the word the next
question you've talked about learning
foreign languages as a sub conscious
process do you think what do you think
do each will when we choose words or I
think my means when we speak do we
deliver the choose words really just
come from I think it's a bit of both
it's a combination of both I think one
thing that's very important when you
learn a language is to trust your
instincts so rather than worrying about
did I choose the right word is this the
right word you know is it grammatically
correct just let it flow out as much as
possible but there is also sometimes we
have the time to think about the word to
think about the right form so to some
extent we do that but the more we can
just trust our instincts and have the
confidence to just assume that all the
work you put into your listening and
reading is just going to enable you to
speak more or less correctly so I think
we just go with the flow is my advice
sounds good when you're using link and
you link a new word what do you do with
it do you study it take an effort to
learn it well you know I love linking
and particularly i like using this sort
of auto link mode where i'm using the
sort of arrow keys and then just going
from blue were two yellow word to blue
it so if it's a blue word of course i'm
selecting it if i need it or I'm if I
know it I mark it as known if I come to
a yellow word then I get to review it
again and so much of my reviewing of
words is when I'm reading on linked in
fact I'll often read a text where I have
have no more new words and it's all
yellow words where I have created links
and I go through again and sometimes I
change the status and sometimes I
changed some of them known so linking
words it's sort of my first contact with
a new word and I know I'm going to meet
up with these words again and again in
the text so that's what I do with it i'm
not a big a lot of people like the
flashcard I do my word review more in
the context of my reading and for those
of you who aren't familiar with the
different modes if you click on the
settings control on the lesson page
you'll see the different available modes
auto mode is the default mode when you
start but some of you may be on
different modes automotive sir is our
preferred mode but obviously there's a
few different options there you should
probably get familiar with but I tell
you auto mode once you get used to it
you go through the lessons very pretty
especially using the keyboard shortcut I
mean if you look at my statistics here
on my 90-day polish challenge I don't
know I think I've increased my known
word total by 10,000 words i think i've
linked 5,000 words I mean I'm right at
the top in terms of the number of links
i create the number of words I learned
it has a lot to do with using that auto
mode mode so i recommend you have a look
at it and get used to it ah next
question how do you deal with proper
nouns on link do you rate them treat
them as normal or do you ignore them
again by and large it is comes up
particularly in Slavic languages where
proper nouns names people names of
places and so forth can have many
different forms because they're declined
just
any other now mostly i marked them as I
IX them I ignore them simply because I
wanted if anything under state my
statistics because in a Slavic language
you're getting so many words as you as
words that you have learned or known
words because you know one or two forms
you know all the other forms so I I tend
to not count the the proper nouns but
you can go either way because to know
that it's not obvious that you know
browse a look in Prague is the same
known as raha Prague so I think it
doesn't matter the statistics are for
your own use whatever you feel
comfortable with good next question it
is I always say obrigada because I am
feminine at least I think so do I always
say Minya or well wrestle mania or male
depends on what i'm referring to that
the agreement is always always with what
you are referring to so when you say
obrigada you are referring to yourself
and if you are a girl or a woman
obviously the agreement there is
feminine because you are saying I am
obligated or I am you know I appreciate
whatever so if you say me Nia my my
mother it's because its mother is family
so the agreement is always with a noun
that you are referring to